on souhaite mettre sa main gauche il
envoie ce papa sport si jamais quelqu'un
méthodes de campagne ses beaux parents
m'ont fait un truc simple quand on veut
la caisse n'a jamais fait l'amour avec
attention
[Musique]
excusez moi je voulais juste vous à
gueule tu veux quand en fait vous montre
ce qu'ils ont l'air de rien avec des
amis oui nouaille berthod nous fait quoi
dans le oui je suis restaurateur c'est
le pizzaïolo du canada oui oui et tout
de bon goût avec des gondoles gt tour de
pise intérieur c'est quoi ça qu'est ce
que vous faites la bande annonce
mais vous êtes défoncer en fait c'est
vrai quoi d'autant que ça qu'on attend
qu elle est où ma soeur
bon je pense à vous et aux enfants tiens
je suis dit que le bonheur est possible
en fait vous épouse devenue sous ce
matin
souza voir ici tous c'est formidable je
voudrais un rein pour avoir votre vie
l'hiver est arrivé là bas si quelqu'un
passe et c'est tout
mon big ben
[Musique]
ça
alors tu voudrais toujours un pour avoir
ma vie encore plus depuis je sais que
tout est à bâle berthoud